a sheriff says the Texas man confessed
to killing his ex-wife just before
hurricane Harvey hit their Houston
suburb crystal McDowell vanished on her
way to pick up their children and take
them to safety before the storm
Steve McDowell is now charged with her
murder he went before a judge yesterday
the 44 year old is being held on a half
a million dollar bond
Omar Villafranca is in Baytown Texas
where crystals car was found Omar good
morning good morning last month crystal
McDowell's car was found flooded in this
motel six parking lot here in Baytown
investigators believe her husband
strangled her in his home with her two
young children still inside wearing
shackles Stephen McDowell seemed to hold
back tears as he appeared in court for
the first time everything in the
investigation leads tested he acted
alone Chambers County Sheriff Bryan
Hawthorne said McDowell admitted he
strangled his ex-wife Krystal and led
investigators to her body it took a
number of different interviews before he
you know confessed one day before
hurricane Harvey hit Southeast Texas on
August 25th Krystal McDowell texted her
boyfriend Paul Hargrave saying she was
on her way to pick up her two children
no traffic today she wrote to him you
are so sweet I knew something was wrong
and because of the conversations we had
had about her ex-husband I I was a bit
concerned when I didn't get a reply back
McDowell was staying at her ex's house
because her home was being renovated the
children ages 5 and 8 were also staying
there she never went ached up her kids
McDowell's car was found abandoned in
this flooded motel 6 parking lot three
days after she vanished so the cops were
here busting in doors
to find out where this lady is police
finally located the 37 year olds body in
a wooded area Saturday the hurricane
hampered the search effort McDowell's
uncle Jeff Walters had reported her
missing her parents thought when she was
young and I guess I'm the closest one to
her in the family she's like my daughter
the sheriff does not believe that her
children actually witnessed her death
they're now in custody of some other
relatives her autopsy was performed
yesterday right now we still don't have
a motive charlie
oh my thanks